Speaker 1: Nikki Haley is now not the only 2024
Republican primary candidate to fail at answering
the question, How is it that you are going to
defeat Donald Trump in this primary? What are
the differences between you and Donald Trump in
this primary? A South Carolina Republican senator,
Tim Scott, who announced his candidacy, which
is completely dead on arrival earlier this week,
he now was asked on Fox News, Trump's crushing
the polls. How is exactly will you defeat him?
And Senator Tim Scott failed or was unwilling to
answer the question in any real way. I'm going to
play the clip for you. He uses words I recognize
they're all English words that I can define. I've
heard these words before. Yet he's not actually
communicating anything. He either has no plan or
he doesn't plan to defeat Trump. And maybe he's
running for vice president. I don't exactly know
the strategy if there even is a strategy. Here's
Tim Scott. And this is not a winning strategy
in the sense that it is not a strategy at all.
Speaker 2: Have to go back to the former president
because his lead is so mighty. How do you take
on someone who literally fights to fight? I mean.
Speaker 3: I know you saw 2016. You saw 2020.
Donald Trump is a master at it. What's your
game plan? Like a plan, a civil one. I'm running
for president, United States that I plan to be
the nominee. So the good news is for the American
people, you will have a stark contrast between me
and the rest of the field. I look forward to
being the messenger that actually adds to our
party without diluting our conservative values.
Speaker 1: Okay. Was there an answer in there?
The answer is no, there was not. Listen, you
you how exactly are you going to be doing brain
transplant surgery in five years when you're
not in medical school? We don't have brain
transplant surgery as a procedure that is done.
Like, how exactly are you going to do it? Well,
listen, five years are going to go by and then I'm
gonna be doing brain transplants. Oh, wow. I guess
I never thought about it that way. That's the
absurdity of what Tim Scott is saying here. You're
losing by 80. I mean, the numbers are completely
ridiculous. How are you going to defeat Trump
here? How are you going to get the support you
need? I'm going to be the party's nominee. Wow.
Pretty amazing that you plan to do that. Using
words I recognize that don't mean anything now.
I got a couple of emails from people saying what
he means is I plan to be Trump's vice president.
I don't actually plan to win. I'm really running
for vice president. And the way I'm going to do
that is similar to the Nikki Haley technique,
which is present myself as an alternative
but don't really attack Trump. Make it this kind
of mild like, well, my identity is different
and then be there when it's time for Donald
Trump to choose his vice president. Very low
energy stuff. A couple other clips from Tim
Scott yesterday on Fox News. Here he is asked
about contrast to other candidates. He says
he's not going to talk about other candidates.
It's going to make it tough to win, my friend.
Speaker 3: I'm not going to focus on the other
candidates in this race. I'm going to focus
on where we should keep the focus. It's on
the American people. Too many of us spend too
much time talking about ourselves. There you.
Speaker 1: Go. He's not going to talk about
himself or the other candidates. That's going
to make it really hard to win. I mean, I don't
I don't know how else to say it. It will be an
extraordinarily difficult task to convince more
than 50% of Republican primary voters to choose
you over the other candidates when you're
polling 1% by not talking about yourself nor
the other candidates, that's really, really,
really strange. And then he says the left is
quaking in their boots. He keeps repeating
this. I haven't heard one person on the left
say they're afraid of Tim Scott. Here's what.
Speaker 3: We're seeing. The radical left
is shaking in their boots because when an
African-American conservative who believes
in the future of this nation stands up to
be counted, they push back. That's a good
sign. We're on the right message.
Speaker 1: So I guess he's saying
the left is scared of him because he's black,
which is a really strange thing to say. Now,
that being said, is he going to run an
identity campaign? And what I mean by
that is Nikki Haley. The only things she really
was willing to draw a distinction with Trump on
seemed to be that she's a woman and she's
younger and she's a person of color.
Maybe Tim Scott's plan is the same, which is I'm
younger and I'm black. I don't know. The problem
is there is no evidence that the MAGA Republican
Party is looking for a black candidate. And I've
already explained to you why that is, and that's
gone back for a while. So not exactly a winning
proposition. And in the meantime, right wing
media and some right wing elected officials
are starting to do the mildly homophobic attacks
on Tim Scott. And you won't be seeing. I didn't
even know Tim Scott was gay. I don't know
that he is. But let's talk about that next.